تتضمن حزمة المساعدة الجديدة هذه
نظامًا جديدًا للطائرات بدون طيار تم تطويره من قبل
القوات الجوية خصيصًا للاحتياجات العسكرية لأوكرانيا ،
دعونا نصل إلى البنتاغون
الآن يحتوي متجر cnn barbara على المزيد
بالنسبة لنا ، أخبرنا بعض
John أثناء إلقاء نظرة على القائمة
البيضاء  إعلان عن المنزل والبنتاغون ،
يمكنك البدء في رؤية بعض الأدلة حول
كيفية قيام هذه المعركة في الشرق
بتشكيل
مدافع الهاوتزر الضفدع على سبيل المثال المصممة
لمنح الأوكرانيين الذين أعتقد أنه من العدل أن يقولوا
أقصى قدر من التنقل يجرون الهاوارد أو
يطلقون النار يمكنهم  حركه بعيدًا عن
عيون وآذان الروس بسرعة كبيرة حتى
لا يتمكن الروس من العثور عليهم واستهدافهم
بهذه الطائرات بدون طيار الجديدة ، هذا
شيء يسمى شبح العنقاء
لم نسمع عن هذا السلاح حتى
اليوم يقول البنتاغون إنه تم تطويره من قبل
الولايات المتحدة  القوات الجوية
للاحتياجات المحددة للأوكرانيين في هذه
المنطقة على غرار الطائرة بدون طيار
التي يرسلونها ، وهذا يعني أنه
مشروع مصنف بطائرة بدون طيار لأنهم
لا يخبروننا بماذا  لكن من المحتمل أن يكون
لديها قدرات مضادة للدبابات المضادة للأفراد
طورتها القوات الجوية الأمريكية
مرة أخرى لتلبية احتياجات أوكرانيا المحددة
وأؤكد ذلك لأننا عندما
بحثنا عن الشركة التي
قال البنتاغون إنها تطور هذه الطائرة بدون طيار
لأوكرانيا ، فهي مقاول أمريكي  هذا
يعمل مع العمليات الخاصة للولايات المتحدة على
وجه التحديد لوحدات العمليات الخاصة السرية في الولايات المتحدة ،
وقد يكون هذا الآن هو
نظام الأسلحة المصنف الثاني الذي تقدمه الولايات المتحدة لأوكرانيا ،
وسوف تتذكر
قبل أسبوعين مناقشة حول
قارب بدون طيار كانوا
يعطونه لأوكرانيا من أجل  احتياجاتهم البحرية
لم نسمع أي شيء عن
تفاصيل ذلك إما أن يقول البنتاغون
إنهم ببساطة لأسباب أمنية لا يمكنهم
الكشف عن أي تفاصيل حول أي من
هذين النظامين ، لذلك يصبح من
المثير للاهتمام للغاية أن أوكرانيا لديها
نظامان من أنظمة الأسلحة المصنفة للولايات المتحدة ينضمان الآن
إلى مخزونها  جون
ويبدأ مرة أخرى ،
أمطار الجحيم تنهمر
على عشرات الأشخاص يختبئون في
قبو منزل قصف بالخارج  في
بلدة robignae ،
دع الأمر يتوقف يا رب يقول الآن هناك
علم أبيض وارد معلق بالخارج بدون أي تأثير
تم قصف المسرح أعلاه
وقصفه مرارًا وتكرارًا
ومع ذلك يظلون
[موسيقى]
فقراء جدًا وخائفين جدًا من الفرار
نينا  89 عامًا هنا منذ خمسة
أسابيع ،
أريد العودة إلى المنزل ، تقول إنني عانيت
كثيرًا ، لقد رأيت النار
والدخان الذي رأيته كل شيء ، أنا خائفة
من نداء نينا ، ساعدنا ببساطة في
مساعدتنا
ابنتها  تكافح لودميلا من أجل
مواساتها بنفسها ،
نحن نصلي إلى الله أن يوقفها
وتقول لسماعنا
يقول ليس لدي مكان أذهب إليه وليس لدي
أصدقاء ولا أقارب
مع القصف المكثف
يجد المتطوعون صعوبة في
توصيل الطعام
حيث تقاتل القوات الروسية والأوكرانية
من أجل السيطرة على رابيجني ، هناك أناس في
الأسفل
يصلون
بينما يسود الجحيم
بن ويدمان سي إن روبيشني أوكرانيا.